so let's apply our life meter to
Earth
so what you know if we were just to
apply assembly index measurements to
Earth what do what what kind of stuff
are going to be get uh are going to get
what's
impressive about some of the complexity
on Earth so we did this a few years ago
in the um when I was trying to convince
NASA and colleagues that this technique
could work and honestly it's so funny
because everyone's like no ain't going
to
work and I was just like because a
chemist was saying of course there are
complicated molecules out there you can
detect that just form randomly I was
like re really that's like that was like
you know it's a bit like
a um I don't know someone saying of
course Darwin textbook was just written
randomly by some monkeys and a typewrite
and just for me it was like really and
the and and I pushed a lot on the
chemist now and I think most of them are
on board but not totally it re really
had some big arguments but the copy
number caught there cuz I think I
confused the chemist by saying one off
and then when I made clear about the
copy number I think that made it a
little bit easier just to
clarify yeah chemist might say that of
course out there outside of Earth
there's complex molecules yes okay and
then you're saying wait a minute that's
like saying of course there's aliens out
there like you yeah exactly that okay
exact but you're you're say you clarify
that that's actually a very interesting
question and we should be looking for
complex molecules of which the copy
number is two or greater yeah exactly so
on Earth so coming back to Earth what we
did is we took a whole bunch of samples
we and we were running Prebiotic
chemistry experiments in the lab um we
took various inorganic minerals and
extracted them look at the volatile
because there's a special way of
treating minerals and polymers and
assembly Theory where what in this in
our life machine we're looking at
molecules we don't care about polymers
because they don't they're not volatile
you can't hold them they're not how how
can you make if you can't assern that
they're identical then it's very
difficult for you to to to work out if
there undergone selection or they're
just a random mess same with some
minerals but we can come back to that so
basically what you do we got a whole
loads of samples inorganic ones M we got
a load of we got Scotch whiskey and also
got took ARB which is one of my favorite
whiskies which is very pey and another
whis do PD mean is like um so the way
that on on um in Scotland in Isa which
is Little Island the the the the the
scotch the SC the whiskey is led to
mature in barrels and um the the it said
that the Pete you know the the the
complex molecules in the Pete
find their way through into the whiskey
and that's what gives it this intense
brown color and really complex flavor
it's literally molecular complexity that
does that and so you know vulka is the
complete opposite it's just pure right
the better the whiskey the higher the
assembly index the the higher index the
better the whiskey that's what I mean I
really love deep PT Scottish whiskies
near my house there is a a one of the
the lowland distilleries called Glen
Goin it's still beautiful whiskey but
not as complex so for fun I took some
Glen coin uh whiskey andard B and put
them into the mass Beck and measure the
assembly index I also got eoli so the
way we do take the eoli break the cell
apart take it all apart um and also got
some beer and and people were ridiculing
us saying oh beer is evidence of
complexity one of the one of the
computational uh complexity people was
just
throwing yeah we kind of kind of he very
vigorous in his disagreement of assembly
theory was just saying you know you
don't know what you're doing even beer
is more complicated than human what we
didn't realize is that it's not beer per
se is taking the yeast extract taking
the extract breaking the cells
extracting the molecules and just
looking at the profile of the molecule
see if there's anything over the
threshold and we also put in a really
complex molecule taxo so we took all of
these but also NASA gave us I think five
samples and they wouldn't tell us what
they are they said no we don't believe
you're can to get this work and they
really you know they gave us some super
complex samples and they gave us two
fossils one that was a million years old
and one was at 10,000 years old um SE
something from Antarctica seabed they
gave us IM merus and meter right and a
few others put them through the system
so I we we took all the samples treated
them all identically put them into Mass
Spec fragmented them counted and in this
case implicit in the measurement was we
um you in mass spec you only detect um
Peaks when you've got more than say
let's say 10,000 identical molecules so
the copy numberers already baked in but
wasn't Quantified which is super
important there this was in the first
paper CU I was like it's abundant of
course um and when you then took it all
out we found that the biological
samples um gave you um molecules that
had an assembly index greater than 15
and all the a biotic samples were less
than 15 and then we took the NASA
samples and we looked at the ones that
were more than 15 or less than 15 and we
gave them back to NASA and they're like
oh gosh yep dead Living Dead living you
got it and um and that's what we found
on Earth um that's a success yeah oh
yeah resounding success um Can can you
uh just go back to the beer and the eoli
so what's the assembly index on those so
what you were able to do is like the
assembly index um of we found High
assembly index molecules origin
originating from the beer sample and the
eoli sample so yeast and the beer I mean
there were I didn't know which one was
higher we wouldn't really do any detail
there because now we are doing that
because one of the things we've done um
it's a secret but I can tell
you I think no nobody's listening well
is that we've just mapped the Tree of
Life using assembly Theory because
everyone said oh that you can't do
infant biology and what we're able to do
is so you I think there's three way well
two ways of doing Tree of Life traff uh
well three ways actually yeah what's the
tree of life so the tree of life is
basically um tracing back the history of
life on Earth all the different species
going back what who evolved from what
and it all goes all the way back to the
first kind of life forms and they Branch
off and like you have plant kingdom the
animal kingdom the
fungi Kingdom you know and different and
different branches all the way up um and
the way this was classically done and
I'm no evolutionary biologist the
evolution biologists are very tell me
every day at least 10 times um I want to
be one though I kind of like biology
it's kind of cool but yeah it's very
cool um but basically what uh what
Darwin and Mel and all these people do
just they draw pictures right and they
they taxa they just con they were able
to draw pictures and and say and say oh
these look like common classes yeah
then they're artists really they're just
you know but they but they they were
able to find out a lot right looking at
verance in verance caman explosion all
this stuff and then um then came the
genomic Revolution and suddenly everyone
used Gene sequencing and Craig vent is a
good example I think he's gone around
the world and his yach just taking up
samples looking for new species where
he's just found new species of life just
from sequencing it's amazing so you have
taxonomy you have sequencing and then
you can also do a little bit of kind of
molecular um uh kind of archaeology like
you know measure the samples and and
kind of form some inference what we did
um is we were able to
fingerprint so we took a load of random
samples from all of biology and we used
mass spectrometry and what we did now is
not just look for individual molecules
but we looked for coexisting molecules
where they had to look at their joint
assembly space and where we we able to
cut them apart and and undergo recursion
in the MC and infer some relationships
and we're able to recapitulate the Tree
of Life using mass
spectroscopy no sequencing and no
drawing